- Is it kind of an amazing thing,
I know you've probably been
asked this a million times,
but to be a part of
something so monumental,
like, so important in pop culture?
Like, everyone rushed home Thursday nights
to watch that show, like, we,
literally, everyone I know watched it.
Like, that's incredible.
- Yeah, it's funny now.
I mean, it felt really huge,
but the way things are now with, like,
social media, and streaming,
and your ability to binge watch something.
That was back before, you
know, they got VRCs back then.
Nobody knew how to
set the thing--
- You had to wait.
- Yeah, but nobody could
figure out how to tape a show.
- I did.
- If you were right there,
you could press record, (laughing)
but, like, to program
it, you got the news.
You know what I mean?
So, but now, it feels
somehow just as relevant now
as it did back then.
- Yeah!
- It's funny 'cause we're
all so much older now.
You know what I mean?
And it's on TV, you think, "God
look at, they're so young!",
and then you come on
and you're like, "Jesus!" (laughing)
- I feel like that with my career as well.
Could you leave the house though,
back in the height of it all?
'Cause I remember we were actually
both at the same award show.
I can't remember what it was.
But it was during "American Idol",
and y'all, or a couple
of y'all were there,
and everybody was swarming around y'all,
and so I was like, "Oh my
God, that's gotta be rough".
- Yeah, well you know,
there's some weird things
that happened, you know, back then.
- Like what?
- I remember one time,
(laughing) so it was
during the week, it was
just like during the afternoon
and I happened to be flipping
channels, I was watching the
news, and for some reason
they had like a split screen
on the TV, six quadrants,
well it wouldn't be quadrants,
but six equal...
- (laughing) Six four.
- And each was a live shot
of each one of our houses,
like a helicopter shot.
"They have the cast of "Friends" houses!",
and I was like, "Okay, what is this,
"what's going on here?",
and I'm watching it,
and it was like a, not,
there was no information,
and no news really,
just showing the houses.
And I remember looking close
at my house and thinking,
"I need a new roof". (laughing)
So the helicopter flies
away, I get the ladder out,
and I go up there, and I'm like, "Shoot!".